what I'm sort of tasked with is to try
to get get you a little more sense of
how to manage these pesky little
volunteer teams that you've now
committed to and so our how to be a good
volunteer on these pesky teams that
you're part of and so part of it we're
going to do today is we're going to a
little activity up I'm in the
organizational behavior group at
Stanford and it's completely impossible
for me to give a lecture okay so it's
just one of I can't do that so we're
going to have some activity and then
we're going to talk about it and so what
I'd like to do is I'll do a brief
introduction to what we're going to be
talking about today then do a little
short activity with these colored sheets
of paper that have appeared on your in
front of you and then we're going to do
a larger activity which is designed to
and many of you may have even done the
activity before in fact I hope that many
of you have done the activity for
because we're going to do a little bit
different twist on it how many of you
have done a desert survival lost at sea
lost at art perfect this is great
alright so we have lots of experts in
the room and so what we're going to do
is we're going to do it but so just do
it and we're gonna do it exactly as
you've done it before except one of the
cool things about exercises is the
debrief can take lots of different
directions we're in think of where I
expect we will take a different
direction from what you did when you did
the you're lost at sea loss of the
desert lost of the moon whatever
exercise okay because I think that's
because and and by the way what we're
going to be debriefing is real
consistent with the research that I do
so I'm actually very interested and
committed to this sort of topic so come
on in and give her a color sheet of
paper so but don't look so one of the
things you know we put people together
in teams for a variety of reasons we put
people together in teams for political
reasons we want to make sure all our
bases are covered I'm not going to
really talk about the political reasons
here let me help you with that
and it's out here human with it I'm not
gonna talk about the political reasons
I'm going to talk about more performance
reasons of the team about why we put
people on teams we put people on teams
because first many hands make light the
work okay so if we have left to go our
teams I as an individual don't have to
do everything and that's actually a real
benefit for teams we also put people on
teams because many eyes looking at the
same problem they see something very
different and in fact we can look at
teams as having really two different
components the component of
implementation and the component of
innovation creativity and the types of
teams and the process of those teams how
those teams function are very different
because their tasks are very different
and so what we're going to focus on here
is sort of first why would we have teams
and that's going to be a pretty quick
because of course we're pretty much all
of us are pretty committed that we all
really know why we have teams right
because it turns out that actually teams
are better do better on average than
individuals so that's great so we want
take advantage of that but they do
better in lots of different ways and
partially the reason they do better is
because not all of us have exactly the
same view of the world and so we look at
emulation Tinh fact there are lots of
creativity researchers and practitioners
who argue that we never actually create
anything new what we do is we put things
together in different ways that haven't
been put together in that way before and
that really is what the majority of us
do when we engage in creative activities
so it's not necessarily you know
creating something out of a new sort of
a new whole cloth but rather taking
pieces of what we know from one set of
expertise and applying it to others and
in many respects as you do your
consulting teams this is exactly what
you're doing you're taking the expertise
that you have and applying it to perhaps
a new or an interesting twist to a
problem you may not have seen before or
you may have seen aspects of or
in fact you you you're simply not going
to implement you're going to actually
create and innovate so first thing I
want to do is give us a little impetuses
to why and the power of teams in the
first place first way I want to do that
if I actually want you to put your hands
on the colored paper but don't turn it
over yet so I want you to have it in
front of all right now when I ask you to
turn it over I'm going to ask you to do
a very simple task I want you to count
the number of s you know the letter F aw
in the sentence that is in that paper
okay and but I might only let you do it
for a very short period of time so I'm
gonna ask you to turn over count the
number of s and I'm gonna ask you to
turn it back over
when I ready set turn it over and count
stop turn it back over okay let me just
ask a question a couple questions how
many people
how many people saw 1f raise your hand
okay
zero how many people saw two F's raise
your hand don't be proud don't be afraid
one two three four this group over here
saw 2x4 that was four not to Maggie try
that again
what happens when you get old you can't
multitask it's really hard
how many will saw three FS 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
how many give us all four FS 1 2 3 how
many we saw 5s 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
how many people saw 6s anybody see more
than 6s
nope okay so we'll just we'll give up
all right now I want you to look at it
again and do the same thing count how
many FS you see ready go
turn it over okay now let's try again
how many people saw 1f okay still nobody
200 3 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
4x 1 2 3 4 5 X 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16
okay just in case you were wondering I
want to remind you this is what we're
looking for okay right this is you got
this is what you're okay yes or this
only at Stanford with that question be
asked all right now what I want you to
do is I actually want you to do a little
buzz group and so unfortunately rooms
not really very set up for it but find
somebody who's close to you and I
actually I want you to do a little group
discussion and Ursula you got to find
somebody maybe maybe Lisa back there
behind you but I want you to take a few
minutes and count how many apps ready
are a few seconds so five your
colleagues and go so where are they
all right that's enough
hello stop time okay I see there's been
some ions in the room all right let's
just check hey you guys let's try now
how many c3 apps
how many C 4 s 5 s 6 s ok now the
question I have is what why did I mean
look at these numbers right I mean there
are you know 24 people and 19 and drop
down back quickly right who we're
looking by the way the colored paper
differences maybe nothing it was Justin
because if you've all had organizational
behavior you know that you have to you
can't trust me right so you know I did
that to sort of say well to justify the
answers because you see they have
different colors of paper you thought
well maybe there's something different
on papers and that's why we see the
difference but no it's not that it's you
right it's your fault this time
so let's think about this why is it that
we got so much variation in what is by
the way an objective task there's
nothing there's nothing subjective about
this right how many FS are in this
sentence so what why is it the people
only ended up with two when you got to
what were you looking at the first
letters right finished files what else
why and then you got another one right
the next most common was to get
scientific and very few of you actually
relatively where did you miss
you missed one of you got one but you
missed one that's really interesting
okay
she had the right dynamic she just
didn't push it all the way through why
do you think you miss me augs
like that it's almost like a process so
your eyes fly over is one pasta it's a
tiny little word yeah just has a visa it
has a V sound so when you say it to
yourself
finished files are the result of years
of scientific oh there's another one
effort at work
I used to say effort pinettes work okay
work right so what happens is when you
say it out loud it doesn't code as a it
closes above right so there's a
difference but of course what happens is
immediately once people got together and
looked at it it was clear you know I saw
a lot of people Gwen oh no that was what
it was right and so part of yeah so this
is a very little call a very
conservative test because this is not
subjective this is not something new
this is very clearly can you simply pick
out the F's in this sentence simple task
right and yet what we see was yeah the
answer is no but what we see is that
getting together in team actually gave
you a different way of looking at the
same objective data and so that's part
of what teams do they allow us to really
sort of get real mean we have a bit of a
focus and that focus that expectation
that theory that we hold drives our
interpretation of data and so what
happens is we find ourselves sort of
being blinded by our theories in this
case you know looking for the sound of
rather than the right you know Oh
what the f Sam whatever it is and so
what happens we find ourselves being
blinded by that and so bringing other
team members who have other competing
theories right it's important so but
it's really twofold in order to be an
effective team you've got to first have
the difference of perspective
but then you've got to be able to get it
raised to the level of awareness of the
team right and it turns out that both of
those are very hard cast to do first to
make sure you've got the necessary
variety on your team and secondly to be
able to actually use that variety right
to have it come out into the into the
team space the intellectual space of the
team so what we're going to do is talk
about those two issues in the context of
desert-survival so actually don't you
say these are all exactly alike not just
completely exactly alike I know now
they're all the same color
now you question okay we don't really
know and let me just sort of go through
this because you have all most of you
have done a variant of this here we may
have a couple in the front row here so
if you guys get lost here in this but as
a group you could hello baby how are you
so this is just the exact exercise
you've done before but turn to the third
I think it's the last page whatever that
page using the second page and what you
see is a is what we're going to be doing
first individually and then as our team
bigger I'll take the extras thank you
okay so as you can read on the front
page basically what's happened is it's
10:00 a.m. it's the desert
it's the Sonoran Desert the Soron desert
the high desert in Arizona
Justin gives an example and your plane
has crashed you're 70 miles
south-southwest of a mining camp the
nearest known habitation and you're 65
miles off the course your visual flight
courses the VFR course that your pilot
put into play
unfortunately pilot the copilot are both
dead only people left are your team
members and in fact what we'd like to do
is when we actually begin the exercise
if I would like you to get into groups
as much as you can of your actual intact
teams okay so if you if there five of
you and your team and there three of you
will may take three from one team and
two from another and put them together
but we'd like you to get into your teams
and basically with groups of about five
people each right there's no more than
five all right there any team that's
more than five here that's five okay
then teams of five or that's the visit
about 30 people here so you should have
about six teams of five
some house or car do you know you could
just get together so there's about five
people I think it should work okay now
it turns out that it's going to be very
hot today 110 which means about a
hundred and twenty five on the desert
floor let's be you know 135 on the
desert floor it's pretty hot
you basically didn't plan on crashing so
what you have in your pockets is two
dollars and eighty three cents and
change eighty five dollars in bills a
pack of cigarettes one of yous a smoker
and a ballpoint pen now before the plane
caught fire and burn to just it's a
little kind of you know skeleton you
were able to pull fifteen items out go
to the second page and you'll see those
fifteen items now the first task we're
going to do is the individual rankings
of these items so what I'd like you to
do to rate one two fifteen one being the
most important to fifteen being the
least important these fifteen items that
would probably take you less than ten
minutes then what we're going to do is
we're going to get together in these
five person teams and we're going to
sort of fit in our buckle upper and
lower we're going to do one people stay
in here because you're going to be
videotaped you know so as the Red Cross
team should stay the Red Cross that you
are the intact team you guys get to stay
hey we'll have a video of your behavior
if we if you lie to us we can go back
and look right then huh on the websites
oh good okay then what we do is as a
team come to an agreement of how these
fifteen items should be rated that
should take another twenty minutes so
pretty much what we're looking at is by
about 10:30 or 10:40 to reconvene little
any of you more precise by 10:40
reconvene back in here with your lists
at which point we will then talk about
what you did and how you might do it
better in terms of these two conditions
right bringing in different
perspectives and getting those
perspectives heard okay any questions
alright so take a few minutes go one
through fifteen and rank the items one
being most important to fifteen being
least important all right now take out
your sheets of paper because I have the
expert now let me give you this the the
credentials of our expert he's a
survival expert who contribute on the
basis of to the item rankings he's the
chief of the desert branch of the Arctic
desert and tropic information center for
the Air Force University at Maxwell Air
Force Base he wrote two books among many
one called survival and the other peopls
of the desert and he's actually really
old because during world war ii he spent
much of his time working with allied
forces on the sahara on desert survival
problems he's dead now okay pretty much
but here's what he said because since we
didn't add any technology to your
experiences number one cosmetic mirror
Oh of all the items the mirror is
absolutely critical it is the most
powerful tool you have for communicating
your presence in sunlight a simple
mirror can generate five to seven
million candlepower of light okay the
reflected sun beam can be seen beyond
the horizon if you have no other items
you would still be better off than an
eighty percent with an eighty percent
chance of being spotted and picked up
within the first twenty four hours so oh
you're not like the second one either
yes if nobody cares you're dead okay
that's it number two top coat once you
have a communication system to tell
people where you are you need to slow
down your dehydration and so forty
percent of the body moisture is lost
through di dishes loss of respiration
and perspiration so you want to keep
that environment around you as moist as
possible to stop to slow down the
evaporation number three the water
a you could probably survive three days
without with just the first two items
just to give you a number for the
flashlight the only quick reliable night
sailing device that you have with the
mirror in the flashlight you have
24-hour signaling capability the
parachute is number five red and white
as a shelter and a signaling device
number six the jackknife it's helpful
for rigging the shelter and cutting into
the tough barrel cactus for moisture yes
yes number seven the plastic raincoat it
turns out this is you can make a solar
still with this yes you can use it to
get water in the desert in the evening
there is moisture and you can get it to
basically condense it could also be
useful it turns out that the physically
required to extract the water selective
use of about twice as much body waters
gain but you know it'll give me
something to do while you're waiting
right number eight the Epistle you think
it's no it's not for food gathering or
killing each other for food gathering by
the end of the second day speech will be
seriously impaired and you might be
unable to walk the pistol would be
useful as a sound signalling device and
the bullet is a quick fire starter
number nine after two days a Stanford
Business School's doing speeches in
there you know it gives us all hope
doesn't it I never came
number nine a pair of sunglasses the
intense sunlight of the desert photo
fella effect their photo Thalia number
10 the compressed gauze kit with gauze
it's not really so useful as you can you
know wrap up wounds because the desert
is actually a very clean environment but
it could be used as rope for wrapping
legs or ankles and face to protect
against dehydration and sunlight so it's
more like a mummy wrap as opposed to a
protection ramp number 11 the magnetic
compass aside from the possibility of
using its reflective services as the
cinnamon device the compass is very is
useless why in fact it's dangerous
because it entices you to think you can
walk out oh yes sexual air map useful
for starting a fire or for toilet paper
number 12 is the sectional map number 13
the book entitled edible animals of the
desert the group is concerned about
dehydration not starvation it can be
used in might contain jor-el's of give
lots of water eat otherwise goat okay
number 14 two quarts of vodka while
severe alcoholism kill someone they
usually die of dehydration or wind
severe alcoholism what alcohol absorbs
water so don't use it the bottle might
be helpful you know you could use it in
terms of helping to start the fire as
the timbre could cool it for your body
and last but not least and I love
because the American Red Cross team has
two physicians in it and they said
absolutely number two by the way this is
from let me do the step oh I am because
I heard it
from the Maricopa County Sheriff's
Department if you walk in the desert
here's what you need to know number 15
salt tablets I know I knew I had to get
some legitimacy up here because both
positions said so tablets number 2
number 15 all right so now I want you to
do as a team I want you to get the make
sure the team is for reliability tell me
what your team score is which is you
want to subtract your the number you
said for an item by the number of the
experts set and it's an absolute number
I don't care about minuses or plus
you're not gonna get that benefit so
just give me the absolute number and
into that third column between between
you want to do yeah so we waited two of
them you I think that you want to do
number step 4 difference between 1 & 3
which tells you how good you are and
then step 5 difference between 2 & 3 how
good your team is and I want your team I
want you to make sure that the number is
correct
oh you know what I hate here's what I
hate I was just telling urban ecology
this outside sometimes you have these
great exercises and then they just go
awry and so the point I'm going to make
is really going to be hard to make with
this group with the possible exception
of GMS exactly but I'm Mickey but I'm
gonna make another point that wasn't the
point that's the general point yes hey
let me tell you the general point which
you guys showed you know sort of in
light and that is you arm well with with
possible exception of one team
that was the one that was recorded you
guys were better as individuals than you
are as a team everybody else right no
one yeah it's at salt tablet thing Oh
let me tell you it was just you were
there right you're in the students
Justin I don't agree with that salt and
the two positions turns in well we're
physicians he said I give oh no here's
the problem right now what's interesting
you have a nametag
give me your name no I'm not doing my
mate this physician said I could be
wrong but I think it's salt and the
other position said salt and so they all
capitulated it's like okay we're going
with the expertise okay
so barring that here's the other thing
we don't see except in this team and
this is what I'm going to talk about
today so I'm gonna you know is that the
best individual was better than the team
right and it turns out by the way if
these were normal teams with normal
people we would see that that pattern a
lot okay so this is it this is really
interesting
and I think part of the problem is so
many of you have done this before you
think you're experts and you drag the
team in very weird ways right sort of
like the expert positions yeah
so let's talk about this a little bit
and try not to mention too many names
this to me you know that would be
interesting what a great experiment no
they were was interested they were very
polite yes they were very polite very
polite and they were also very rational
how about this mad mad build on that
comment please you know that's what they
did and so that was sort of wait hand up
yeah yeah how many of you walked out how
do you walked out you're dead you can't
do it I had this group I heard them this
is not their fault
I heard they said we can do 20 miles a
night in what alternate universe can you
drive through the desert 20 miles in a
nightgown but they had so Chaplin so
they were okay I know well let's go just
like some individuals who are highly
highly you know sort of physically fit
might be able to walk out but let me
tell you the average reasonably fit
person can't do that and certainly not
for two nights right
think about this you know you guys I
know it's tough get Noah but we got to
kind of acknowledge these things so it's
like well when I was 16 I could have
done that yeah okay
all right well KITT what we want to talk
about and I'm going to talk about anyway
regardless of what you guys did or not
because this first part was fun anyway
its first synergy which you did have and
that is that the individuals didn't do
on average did not do as well as the
teams right and in many respects that
really is the first component right
that's the first component of any reason
why we bring to use together because we
get this huge advantage of synergy right
that people coming together raise issues
that would not have otherwise yet you
might not have thought about as an
individual and so whenever there's a
situation where you don't really know
the answer then teams can provide a huge
risk
to you now secondly so the benefit the
big benefit of teams is synergy the big
cost of teams is process loss and we
didn't actually see much process loss
here but the process loss would be
replicated here as where the individual
where at least one individual or
typically typically one and sometimes
more do better than the team does and
that's a real loss because what happens
is you have a one member of the team who
by themselves
seems to have been hurt by the
interaction and what I want to focus on
because the type of topic or at least
the titles you can sort of see is
getting your voice heard and part of
what makes us more effective as teams is
that we take advantage of the potential
that exists within the teams and the
question is how are we able to do that
how can we actually accomplish that
they're actually alright go back now
well process loss is the inability of
groups to take advantage of the of the
intelligence the intellectual property
that exists within their teams and
process loss comes from a lot of
different things now I want to talk a
little bit about these four compare
these four conditions they obviously did
not occur here so let's just talk about
them hypothetically because in these
groups they didn't happen but they do
happen
one is we did see actually expertise
right expertise
you know sometimes expertise is real and
sometimes you look expertise is there's
expert enid if it doesn't really apply
to the problem right and so something
can get distracted see I'm looking up
now you can look distracted from that
expertise let me let me what is
interesting studies
I call it us actually my student did
have a doctoral students down to faculty
at Kellogg and she did a very
interesting study using this exercise
and what she did was she put brand the
exercise and then looked at teams in
their performance when a male was the
most expert member and a female was the
most expert member oh yeah and notice
that as you saw here you didn't know who
the most expert member was team didn't
know right until after the fact right so
now what did she find she found any
difference in performance of those two
groups yeah of course I wouldn't be
mentioning it would I run out of 100
difference okay move on
oh I know so what happened when the
expert most expert member was male the
teams did better oh I know Beth you're
going to see us on the other way didn't
you Oh hon you did too huh now it turns
out the male's that well there's two no
there's two hypotheses from that from
that study you cannot disentangle the
two alternative explanations one is
though females who are more expert spoke
and nobody listened or they didn't speak
they self-censored it's probably a
combination right because now of course
yes to do the second study to find out
which it was but I can tell you from my
experience and teams it's probably a
combination first people say this is not
a task that I'm a particular expert in
so the things I think are kind of silly
maybe I won't even bring them up right
or I bring them up and people say excuse
me were you a boy scout did you ever do
this stuff right no so part of it is
that you get a sense right of
contribution is really a function of
people's expectations about people's
quality of contribution independent of
necessarily the objective quality of
that contribution and so part of this is
as a team leader what I've got to be
very sensitive to is I may see these
kind of patterns developing where
certain people are put into boxes and
those boxes don't allow them either to
contribute or allow their contributions
to be actually way over weighted right
so this is Amin it's a very hard task
because you never really know how well
you're doing until the end right in this
kind of process also what happens is
people this is an assist or dinner and
expertise and expectations assumptions
all kind of go together but coalition's
may form right did you find these teams
or have you found other teams you've
been into this they're sort of a
dominant coalition that's that forms and
their way gets it when perhaps you know
other people may resist what the two
positions I wasn't going to say that
so coalition's coalition formation is a
very powerful force in teams and it can
be a force for good or ill right
typically though the problem is is that
where it's very hard for us to tell
whether it's good or ill because if
we're in the coalition it's for good and
if we're not is for ill right but what
coalition's do is they tend to reduce
the influence of the minority and that
can be very dangerous okay so as long as
we have a dominant coalition we have
enough people to sort of bull through
and get it done and the minority becomes
you know so many chattering voices out
there that we don't pay attention to
could be suppressing or avoiding
conflict you might in fact many teams
find conflict a very scary experience
and so what happens is they tend to
suppress differences rather than to
engage the differences and as a general
rule if your task is to learn you have
got to engage the differences because
yeah yep it is absolutely challenge
because one of the things that we're
going to you know what happens is what
you want to be able to do in at any kind
of team interaction is engage the
dispute right that is began to create
dissonance but you have to resolve it
you have to come you have to now come to
consensus right so you have this first
you have this sort of throwing the issue
open and bringing it back down the
problem that you suggest is what it's
very important if you don't manage your
team time and you end up with dissidents
dissonance dissonance your team will
will actually perceive that conflict
even though it might be conflict which
we term conflict of diverse of debate or
controversy good kind of conflict if you
can't resolve that the team will
reinterpret that is emotional an
interpersonal conflict and the team will
begin to disobey ceccolini is kind of it
won't function and so part of it is at
the team lead you got to be real
clear about that agenda you know one of
the good things by the way they did many
good things one of the good things you
can see on the tape is they had a person
who specifically watched the clock in
this team in here and many of you may
have done that as well right to make
sure you didn't get caught up in this
kind of discussion and you'd have time
to come back and make sure you got to
the end and by the way I want to just I
want to congratulate all the teams from
actually this was pretty punctual given
how these teams usually are you did
really good and getting the teams in
here okay
so let's break this down into three
different problems excuse me composition
participation and influence now I'm
going to actually leap across
composition because your teams are
already formed but what I've given you
is some ideas about when and why you
might want to use more homogeneous
versus more heterogeneous teams it is
not the case that always you want is you
want maximum diversity nor is it the
case that you always want maximum
homogeneity right
typically the sort of the categorization
is if implementation homogeneity if
innovation creativity learning
heterogeneity in your teams why because
we don't like to learn we don't like to
think we only learn if there is
motivation to do so and that motivation
typically comes in the form of here's
what I think the world is like and my
observations don't match that so I've
got to have some discrepancy the way I
create discrepancy in a team is to have
people with different perspectives and
views of the world and then we work it
out right so if I don't have that if
everybody has the same opinion there's
not going to be any learning because
there's no impetus no way to no reason
to force us to use those scarce
resources okay so that's we're going to
sort of leap right across that no that's
more than the nine there's more that
here's more I had a really nice set of
slides but
aha the participation problem well this
is probably what you're going to find
yourselves now that you have your team
formed you're going to find yourselves
having a real issue with participation
it's a very common team problem and with
participation it is a learned behavior
right people and so that's one of the
reasons sort of and for those of you had
most of your team here at this and had
this as your kind of quasi first team
meeting turns out that this is actually
a good thing because there was probably
a lot of participation and so you and
you basically created a norm by your
first team meeting that there's this
kind of good-natured participation right
even it was on something silly like
desert survival it's whatever you are in
a team the first meeting is absolutely
critical it is it will set the stage for
how the rest of the team's life goes and
so at that first team meeting and what
by the way a lot of things that Cynthia
said in her first session I'm going to
reiterate here because she gave you a
nice little set of to do's about how to
think about managing your team but one
of the things that's really important is
don't underestimate that first team
meeting to set the norms about
communication and participation it's a
learned behavior even people who don't
like to talk in public may find that in
a team where the expectation is they
contribute they will let me give you an
example I used to go to Thailand and
teach for every year for a couple of
months right a couple of weeks I lived
in Chicago at the time was at Kellogg
and let me tell you February in Chicago
and they said hey you want to go to
Bangkok I might pick me let me get out
of here like so I would go there and the
first time I went you know and one
things I do you notice I don't actually
speak from notes and stuff it's what you
know the my notes are back there you
guys see them the same way I do but if I
can't get interaction this doesn't take
very long right
so I go to Thailand I have all class I'm
teaching and I have my you know three
note cards or three sets of overheads
right that I put out there and the first
day of class of a three-hour class I
finish in about 45 minutes I'm done I've
done everything I thought I had plan to
do there was not one comment one
question there was not one engagement
from the audience of 65 MBA students
okay so I'm thinking to myself oh no
this is gonna be really bad
so I into the class of boats you know
it's the first day it's a short class
right and I'm just because I'm in
Thailand it's like I could bring more
stuff right it's already there right and
so I'm thinking ah this is good we're
gonna be finishing about it you know one
and a half classes will be done right
what do we do and so as I close my books
to get ready to leave the line formed
right and they started asking questions
completely reasonable questions I said I
said to the student unfortunate poor guy
was the first one said why didn't you
ask this in class and they said
professor we couldn't and I went why not
you know I'm used to but you know think
about Stanford we can't ask questions
yeah right all right and they said well
because professor if we asked you a
question in class you would lose face
because you actually hadn't ants
basically done a good job of explaining
the material to us therefore if we ask
questions we're calling you to question
your your capability your
professionalism your expertise and I
said that's really interesting because
you see in my culture when you don't ask
a question it says I haven't engaged you
and so I lose face if you don't ask
questions and they look at me and say
autumn this is hard
so however being you know you know was
the necessity as the mother of invention
I came into class the next class period
with a bunch of red 3x5 cards and I
handed one out to each student in class
and I said in order to pass the class
you must turn in your need to speak card
that's what this is the need to speak
okay and so you do it and by the way
write your name on the card because I'm
going to get it collect and if by the
end of class you have not turned in this
card you have failed the class now what
does it need to speak card I need to
speak card is you can ask questions
you'll get two turned in or you can say
if you hold up your red card and there
are other people talking you get first
call I'll call you first but at the end
of the class you need to turn in you
have got to have that card turned in
well it turns out that what I was doing
was changing the nature the structure of
the class to force them at least ask one
question each right knowing that if I
opened the gates right if I got them to
talk they would talk more because then
it was acceptable and so part of this is
understanding that you have to think
about how do i structure the team
meaning my team interactions such that
people not only have permission but feel
the responsibility to talk to contribute
group size buton sometimes we have large
groups and it turns out that group size
is also problematic if I have a group of
twelve let me tell you you can hide in
there you don't have to talk because
there's enough people there the air time
will be taken and so you can spectate if
that's the case if you find yourself in
those kinds of situations or even in a
group of six sometimes people tend to
hide you might want to try what's called
buzz groups because while you can hide
with a group of six you can't hide in a
group of two right so I say okay I want
you two to talk about we're going to
we're going to break down to sort of
subgroups because this is an issue we
have some disputes over let's talk about
subgroups
and I want you to talk about this issue
for five minutes we're going to come
together as back to the larger group and
figure out what the solution is going to
be right I'm forcing you now to
communicate because if there's two of
you
you can't not talk to the person sitting
next to you that you've just sit in the
bus group right
Oh usually were told to do it as
teachers is to recognize here then go
over here then go over here then go over
here right completely blocking little
natural tendency or in this case so they
did that with room space they also do it
with gender or race so if a woman speaks
now go to a man a man speaks try to go
to a woman well what happens is you
block because proximity and similarity
tends to get people increases the
probability they'll talk right so you
need to sort of understand these
naturally occurring social factors that
allow people to speak well there's also
the influencer problem right influence
is why teams meet you want to be able to
be influenced and to influence other
members of your team I learn best when I
get your ideas before they're influenced
by mine this is a problem though right
how can everybody go first
think about this have you ever done a
brainstorming session tell me about tell
me the rules for brainstorming that you
used how did you huh that's good no
judgment that's it that's you these way
so any idea no evaluation okay anything
else anybody did let's write one down
first huh
everybody gets to write that see see
this is the way to start a brainstorming
session if as most people start
brainstorming sessions you just said
let's all get together and throw up
ideas and no evaluation okay this is a
bad way because as soon as the first
idea is thrown up it influences
everybody else and the point is we in
the reason it's so powerful is because
we don't
think it does we think we can sort of
you know be separate from but in fact we
are dramatically influenced by that and
so as a result what happens is that
setting being a first mover right gets
you to have much more influence in the
group by your first idea statement or
your willingness is our stated position
early on than any of the subsequent
contributions by other group members in
fact I had a colleague of mine a social
psychologist who knew this work and
actually practiced it in faculty
meetings so when there were someplace he
wanted to go he was I mean hidden wait
for it was like let me tell you what I
think the right answer is right and
dragged all of us there right even
though we may have disagreed
we now modulated our disagreement in his
direction and he knew it he was great
one hey if you know that stuff use it
right well there are two effects I want
to talk about and em influence I want to
talk about yeah sure
focal catholic to instigate comments now
from what you've said there's a high
likelihood decision will go your way
yeah somebody do do it at your own
volition but you said okay Brad your
idea tend to go that way as well if they
thinks it does yes because what happens
is we don't remember why people spoke
what it's not that it's not that people
spoke first because they're they are
compassionate or I'm sorry passionate
about the idea
they spoke first it's the speaking first
right and so part of what I mean and
actually I was looking I have a slide
that's arose before which basically
gives you a whole list not a whole list
a small group of I have it in here
someplace there it is slide 29 we're
just going to leap around here right you
want you don't want to it you're the
team lead you think you may be giving
your suggestions because you want to
sort of provoke the group well what
happens when you do that is you
influence the group so you want to start
with some perhaps with some writing
prewriting people sort of make a they
write about what they want to their the
ideas are before they get influenced in
vertical groups and this is response to
you you want to actually have
participation in verse relationship to
the power of the group so you want low
low power people low status people a
group to speak first the high status of
the leader to speak last because you
know you've all been in teams in your
organizations where as soon as this that
the the leader speaks the CEO speaks we
all say sounds good to me let's go right
but what that does is it destroyed why
then why are we at you know why are we
having this team why don't you send the
memo out this is what I want you say
okay fine right we don't need the team
there and you want to model and
encourage dialogue over advocacy right
which is let's talk about why as opposed
to I want I want to win those are the
two distinctions
so let's go back a little ways now oh
that was wrong let's try this again 14
there so there really are two things
when you with what influence does is it
changes people in two different ways or
can change people's perceptions in two
different ways the people's verbal or
outward views of what what their
agreements are what their opinions are
and it turns out we could have both an
informational and a normative
perspective and the first one is that we
often determine especially in ambiguous
situations what to do by looking around
and saying well what's everybody else
doing which is why the first meeting is
so important because what we're doing
here is is that teams are kind of an
ambiguous situation this is a you know
all of my consulting team how do you
behave in that team right and so we look
around to see what the norms are what
everybody else is doing and secondly it
turns out when we don't have we don't
know what the correct response is we are
dramatically influenced by our
environment the whole psychology of mobs
right is exactly this we don't know what
to do we go with the mob we look at what
the rest of the the large group people
are doing and we've mirror that now
here's my one of my examples of
informational proof the the woman of the
staircase says I don't buy stocks easily
because others are buying them I buy
them because many others are buying
right so I need lots of people to tell
me this but let me so what happens is in
we're in a situation where we don't know
what the right answer is we look around
to try to find what that answer is and
what happens is that we get influenced
and people will look to others but they
look to it as information unfortunately
or fortunately you decide which what
happens is we get anchored by it it
turns out that we look to it as we act
as if we're gonna have a little input
into this it'll be just like one
component of the input it has a huge
impact
has such a huge impact because we don't
think it has an impact like a first
offer in a negotiation you'll probably
some of you know my teaching winter was
she going to get negotiation in here yes
okay first offer in negotiation we all
know it's extreme right and we think we
discount for the extremity of the first
offer but objectively we don't discount
enough so what happens is we're still
influenced in that direction but even
more so because we think oh we aren't
taking care of that right we would we've
adjusted for that
well what informational influence does
is it changes our private view of the
situation so it's a private we actually
change how we think about things based
upon what other people are doing let me
give you an example informational
conformity bystander apathy this is a
classic social psych experiment but then
if they put two three people in a room
you start seeing the three this is like
a room with a chair three chairs in a
table and here is the subject the person
who is actually the only naive person in
the room the other two people have
scripts about how to behave but the
subject doesn't know that the other two
are in cahoots so what happens is
they're in a room and they're asked to
fill out a relatively extensive survey
and as they're filling out this form
you know filling out the questions
suddenly from the closet a huge billow
of black smoke comes out of the closet
under the door the subject looks up and
you can they've got it video to you Mike
looks up sees the smoke looks around at
the other two there calmly filling out
the paper and he goes back in Tommy
fills out his paper okay you laugh you
have done it too how many of you have
fire drills in your buildings and you
say well it's just a drill do you know
that you know my response is if there's
a fire drill I'm walking out cuz I can't
tell and wouldn't I be irritated for
eternity if it turned out to be real and
I died okay I mean just
but what happens is this person says
this is a weird situation okay even
better
airplanes you've been an airplane you've
flown and it's a big cuff thunk you look
immediately to the flight attendants are
they anxious if they're not nothing okay
are you going yeah we've all been there
and then I've already talked about
anchoring I haven't got enough time to
talk about of that so you can read this
yourselves it was a very cute example
here's some more hey I got six minutes
left okay let me just tell you if you
haven't heard me talk about the
anchoring and adjustment study on real
estate it's a good one all right this
was this is a really good like okay now
the normative basis for conformity you
know they told me I only had two hours
and this is really a three hour talk so
what can I say you know I did want you
to not get it you can read about it the
normative basis is actually as powerful
the info informative basis of conformity
the normative basis says I want to be a
good team player I want to be part of
the group this is why there's such a
notion of conformity right because we
believe that what a good team is is a
team that is without conflict that is
that it's basically a lot of agreement
also others who may want to have a
particular goal in mind and we want to
get out of the meeting right provide
rewards and punishments to us and we
want to see we want to get those rewards
and avoid those punishments so we
oftentimes accommodate the majority now
interestingly when informational
conformity changes my private opinion
here you get public compliance but not
necessarily internal change so I may say
yes but I don't really mean it but I'm
doing it as an expediency and for those
of you who haven't ever seen this is the
Asch experiments it is actually these
for the original guys in the Asch
experiment subject number six is the
only subject the other six people are
Confederates
and their what they're looking at is
this example and they're basically asked
which line is quote which of line a B or
C is closest in length of the standard
right and the answer of course is C all
of you knew it how surprisingly okay
it's not a hard thing what happened was
in the ash experiments is the six other
Confederates were told answer B okay
he's hearing B B and he's looking he's
go wait what so I mean it's like what's
wrong
it's C he's thinking to himself it's got
to be C right mmm and thirty five to
forty percent of the subject sixes when
asked what's a lot which line is it says
C knowing that it's B but they look
around say B knowing that it's C right
you go thank you I'm glad you were
listening that was a test
okay so part of it is that they
accommodated right
they gave a public compliance but
clearly they knew that it was not be it
was C and it by the way it turns you can
get even more compliance if there's some
connection between the individual and
the other six people for example they do
this is a group of high school students
and they put wrestling team members and
it was their wrestling team the other
five six members of the group were
wrestling team members who said B you
had a much higher percentage of the
other wrestling team member the subject
saying B right group connectedness group
compliance you saw that one already
mmm so here's some to dues or some
suggestions for you and getting your
voice heard first here's the first one
you need to express yourself if you
disagree with your team if you believe
that where the team is going is not the
right place you need to talk about it
you need to take the responsibility to
put that information
out there for the team maybe even
multiple times right because what's
going to happen is the team is going to
want to engulf you to say you know we
really really can't accommodate your
concerns just come along with us right
it's the ameba response right let me
just golfy so that you know you're good
you're gonna be one of us don't worry
about it right you need to be able to
present solid justifications for why you
disagree and you also need to
differentiate your perspective so I need
to get you the majority tell me why my
my concerns aren't critical right you
have to convince me as I need to
convince you that they are very
different and my outcome my perspective
is very different so I had to I have to
sharpen the distinction between you and
me between the minority and the majority
because the minority and majority
majority what's conformity that's one of
the real goals of majority is to get
everybody to agree now it's really
interesting a Deborah grünfeld you may
know if you've actually been here for a
short period of time but if you haven't
is a faculty member here at Stanford and
she does a lot of work on power and she
has her dissertation did a really cool
study and what she did was she went she
got the decisions of the Supreme Court
and categorized them whether they were
unanimous decisions or majority minority
decisions and then she evaluated what
they call the integrative because what
she called the integrative complexity of
the decision that is how logically
argued and complete were the decisions
and then she looked at whether those
that were more logically argued and more
complete were as a result of unanimous
or as result of a majority minority and
it turns out very clearly if you look at
these two different types of decisions
by the Supreme Court it doesn't matter
how many years you go back right you
just I mean so whether they're
Republican or democratic courts doesn't
really matter right but you go back you
find that the more integrated lis
complex decisions came when there was a
majority and a minority because the
while they may not have been accepted
had to be considered and in doing so the
logic and the complexity of the
arguments were much higher okay so the
decisions were better because there was
a minority even if the minorities
opinion did not hold and what happens if
you are a minority opinion holder it
depends how you how you convey that
differs whether your group is typically
homogeneous are typically heterogenous
if your team is typically homogeneous
that is for example and you can you
might be able to do this depending on
how you characterize it here you are
your enact team and you're all from
Stanford okay so if you want to you want
to play that if the team is primarily
homogeneous you say you know what we're
all we're all from the same background
we're all together I'm all I'm one of
you guys and I disagree you basically
call the commonality and then say what
you disagree about what you don't want
to be in a homogeneous team is what we
call a double minority that is you
disagree and there's something weird
about you okay that's a bad place
because your team will reject you for
that right oh yeah there is there he
goes again he always does that because
he's you know he made your heat when he
matrix because he's in marketing and
they're weird okay if you are for
example the only marketing person in a
group of finance majors so maybe that's
how your team has talked about itself
you want to highlight your difference
because everybody knows you're not a
finance person okay you're a marketing
person why do we have a marketing person
there must be a reason for that right
there's a reason for your difference so
what you do then in those situations is
you highlight your difference you
actually want to be a double minority
you highlight your difference here's why
I was brought on board
I brought a board because of my
different perspective and now let me
tell you why I disagree and it turns out
that teams
actually are more influenced if you
compare how influenceable teams are by a
minority member who comes from it was a
duck but in this case a double minority
in a home which in a heterogenous group
than a double minority in a homogeneous
group although you expect that if we're
all together and all alike
I'd be more influential turns out it's
not true because because we're so alike
we really resist conflict and dealing
with differences we suppress them much
more so than if there's some obvious
heterogeneity in the group find an ally
among the incumbents right this is a
really good slew by the way this is a
really good tool especially for example
if you're a new member right if you're a
new member you are going to be more
effective if you've got some if you can
basically find some way to ally with one
of the old-timers the incumbents and by
the way this research has been supported
in corporate boards of directors where
it turns out that if you're sort of a
minority member on the board you're much
more effective if one you've been a
minority member on other boards or other
board members have been minority members
on the boards they've been on it makes
you much more effective and so making
those connections can enhance your
effectiveness consider your motives and
choose your fights if you are that type
of person who always likes to be that
contrarian this is a dangerous position
because your group will eventually
ostracize you and they may let you still
sit in the room but they won't pay any
attention to you right as a team lead if
you've got somebody like that in your
group you need to assign roles and you
need to say you know what Vivian today
you are the contrarian Cynthia you're
not what you're going to do today is
you're going to be basically you're
going to manage that you're gonna
facilitate the discussion that's your
job right so what you've got to do is
because otherwise every time Cynthia if
Cynthia is the contrarian every time she
speaks the group kind of just goes there
guys glaze over you know it's like there
she goes
again alright wrap up being a good team
member or a good team leader requires
three characteristics preparation teams
don't function without some hard thought
and consideration about how to do well
what are we trying to accomplish how can
we get there you need to actually think
about it we swear we are in social
groups all our lives but that doesn't
mean we know how to run a team you've
got to think about this stuff secondly
connectedness teams create the team
becomes an entity we are connected one
things that used to amaze people and it
certainly made me when I first found out
about it and sort of observed it in one
of my past lives I used to be a marriage
counselor and family therapists and
families would come to you know see us
and they would say you know what Ron is
the problem our son Ron is the problem
fix him William and you know what if
something happened and Ron was like went
away to boarding school or went away to
jail or went away then what would happen
is they'd say you know what it's our
daughter Cynthia now she's the problem
because it wasn't Ron or Cynthia or any
of the other siblings right it was the
family system that had a problem and so
if you have a contrarian in your group
and you ostracize that person there will
be another one that arises in your group
to take that role because the group
needs it that's something happening in
the group you need to consider so you
need to think about the
interconnectedness and not say if we
could just get rid of X our lives would
be wonderful because they won't be
because Y will show up and behave in MIT
and surprisingly the same way you need
to deal with the problems not things
that they'll just go away through
attrition and finally you need to
develop discipline and emotional
maturity one of the things that we know
is that teams don't like conflict team
members don't like conflict so we try to
suppress ignore you know reorient
anything just so we don't have to
with conflict conflict is absolutely
critical for people to learn and so part
of what you guys are going to be doing
is engaging these kinds of learning
activities you need to encourage
conflict people need to be willing to
basically ask the hard questions and
engage in emotionally uncomfortable
situations for the good of the team if
you care about the team and that's part
of what you need to think about getting
the team members willing to to have
enough commitment to the team that
they're willing to engage in these tough
discussions choukri structures mean such
I mean part of the structure I gave was
I start talked a lot about structure so
how does the first meeting work you want
to structure the first meeting right so
you may also in terms of structuring you
may want to think about how what other
issues you need to address net first
meeting this is not on my slides let me
give you another point that you need to
think about let's have a in our first
meeting we need to have a time when we
talk about what are the goals and
missions of this team what are we trying
to accomplish because one of the most
critical aspects of team performance is
commonality of goal and mission among
the team members so I would strongly
encourage you to start a meeting with
these kinds with this kind of discussion
so that you get some commonality and
commitment to those goals and missions
that will be that will push you a long
way the team that believes that that
members have common goals and missions
can handle a lot more conflict
successfully than teams that are
wondering why are you really here right
so that's a really important point
setting assigning roles is another form
of structure right so if you find people
to naturally take on certain roles you
know simply said work to your strengths
absolutely but you've got to watch out
that some of these people some people
may see their strengths being the
contrarian that's not a good role for
someone to take okay assign that role
basically get people involved with it so
when people do make these contrarian
statements it's not seen as a personal
tribute okay so there's some examples
all right I'm now nine minutes over yes
go ahead
probably not but they could be
I mean people I mean what would happen
is it takes the pressure off people to
be contrarians right so I might say okay
well okay it's best turn to be a
contrarian so I know that's why I mean
so it can't be Beth we got to put in
somebody else so we're gonna let Tony be
the contrarian now because you've been a
contrarian too much but what it means is
that it might dampen your natural
predilection to do that yes but it might
also open up you might get a little more
other people being willing to speak
because they can't that they Tony may
not be as good as you are and force that
a little bit like yes they might yeah
Beth yes they might but that might be
good for you Beth I know but it may not
be fun it's so much more fun to say
uh-uh
all right thank you very much